it's a far cry from Scotland where golf is
supposed to originated to the wedded States
the game must be good to have Indians discard
their bows and arrows for a set of clubs and
some little white golf balls long before Columbus
discovered America this ancient game was played
and it's taken all these years for it to catch
up with the original Americans but now the big
chiefs and the little chiefs ride their mounts
to the fairways hit the ball with the might of a
[ __ ] and they do tell them that a lot of wampum
passes hands when they reached the 19th hole
you can't get away from it no matter where you
go even a top snow-covered plateaus and rugged
mountains the golf enthusiasts must have their
fling or their drive and up here the golf ball
is colored red this climate is for those players
who get hot under the collar or all steamed up
over missing an easy putt here the charm of the
game is enhanced by the Arctic like scenery with
greens that are white and fairways that
are really ski trails it's a new thrill
in the ever-increasing popularity of an ancient
sport professional or amateur top-notch golfers
always attract huge galleries that keenly follow
every player and every shot here's a player who
attracts a lot of attention it's Jack Redmond
with his collection of amazing golf clubs Jack
whittled this one out of the head of a bowling
pin and he can hit him straight with that one
as he can with a regular driver left-handed
clubs are no setback for this Redmond fella
he just turns the head upside down takes a heavy
swing and smacks the ball right onto the green
Jack brought this one from Ireland
he calls it his shillelagh Club and
he almost smacked the cameraman with
this drive some golfers feel stiff
and tight when they start out Jack
recommends this club to loosen up
and for long shots here's the answer
here's a fancy Club for fancy players
a practice swinger - and he's ready
but this too is a trick club it's called
the magnetic driver for the atomic age
here's another golf magician it's John
Montague and his specialty is playing
golf with a shovel and playing a better game
than those who sport a set of expensive clubs
seeing is believing
when it comes to putting Montague is an
expert especially when the handle of a
spade serves as a putter 9 balls lined up
in a row and now you see them now you don't
every golf book stresses the rule keep your eye on
the ball but Jack Redmond debunks that one all you
have to do is memorize where you put the ball
then hit it while you're enjoying the scenery
jack is quite an unpredictable player as a matter
of fact he seldom knowledge yet what he's going to
do next hitting these balls in proper order would
be too simple too conventional for this trickster
watch this one balance two balls one atop
the other swing catch and there you are
a slow-motion camera analyzes the absolute
precision of the shot you'll have to be accurate
ensure or instead of a free catch you might
get a free black eye another one watch this
it's a clean shot at the middle ball and if you
don't believe it watch this slow motion analysis
sometimes Redman discards his
tricks and really plays the game
but overconfidence is dangerous and even the
best players slip up when they least wanted
right into a sand trap and bad - and Jack says
shucks or something but there's sabotage your
foot ordinarily it wouldn't be too difficult
to drive out of this predicament but it's a
different proposition when somebody walks in
and buries the ball Jack could argue with a
man but when a pretty girl is the villain
that's different now he has to be his own
golf ball detector that's not so easy in a
miniature desert of sand but perseverance
has its own reward a little more detecting and
now he's on the trail anyway it's worth a try
a hefty swing a cloud of sand and out comes the
pill and over onto the green and not
too far from the cup for an easy putt
not to be outdone Montague purposely
covers the ball plant sits well down
in the sand again he uncovers
a most remarkable golf shot
watch these shots closely and see
what long hard hours of practice
can accomplish its wizardry on the fairways
oh well he's allowed to miss one once in a
while one thing that never worries Redmond
is being stymie in slow motion Jack shows
how to get out of trouble and into the cup
there's that villain shoe again but this time jack
takes his revenge and while she prays
he aims and it's a drive par excellence
here's another bit of magic that
anyone can do if you know how six
balls and six putts each one landing
in the cup as straight as an arrow
it looks easy and it is easy but first you
must do as Redman does set the alarm clock
so that you will be up and out to the green before
anyone is around lay the flagstick on a straight
line with the cup pound it into the turn and
there you have a ready-made groove or track
well sue me says jack but catch me first
as a finale to a great exhibition Montagu again
picks up his trusty Spade and delivers
a shot that staggers the imagination
the wise golfers will tell you to start them
young if you want them to become experts as
soon as the young generation can walk hand in a
club and let them swing to their heart's content
this little tot says it's easy
to putt the ball into the cup
but it's too much trouble to get it out